in Toronto there's a basketball fan like
no other I breathe drink everything
about the Raptors basketball is truly my
whole life is around the Raptors see
deeply for the last 22 years I have
never missed a game a Raptors superfan
[Music]
my name is na Bhatia and I'm Raptors
superfan if you've watched any Raptors
games in the last decade maybe you've
noticed the bearded man sitting
courtside
well that's knob and his story starts in
India and takes him right here to Canada
fleeing violence not left and settled in
Toronto
he worked hard opened a very successful
car dealership when the city had its own
NBA franchise the Raptors arrived and I
bought my first two tickets I enjoyed
the game I was sharing the most in the
whole arena the team embraced him and
being a super fan has its perks
when the legend Kobe Bryant came for his
last game to Toronto he came to me and
said super fan I want to thank you
what you have done because you have
created a culture of bringing everybody
together through this game of basketball
he also gets to hang with Canadian
royalty had I know Drake pretty well but
what's most important about enough super
fandom is that he represents the
changing face of basketball fans around
the world basketball has changed my life
tremendously it has given me an
opportunity to integrate my community
the South Asians into the mainstream not
maybe the first Raptor super fan but he
wants everyone on board I want to see
this game taking to the next level we
are all the communities everybody that
the Hindus the Muslims everybody coming
to the game
[Music]